Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Riccardo Sasso
E se adesso vi dicessi che qui fuori
sono appena atterrati gli alieni?
Mi prendereste per matto.
Esattamente 85 anni fa,
la mattina del 31 ottobre 1938,
i quotidiani americani
titolarono proprio così:
un'ondata di panico,
causata dalla trasmissione radiofonica
"La guerra dei mondi",
del celebre regista Orson Welles,
aveva portato centinaia di americani
a scendere in strada
convinti che fosse in atto
un'invasione aliena!
So cosa state pensando: "Americani..."
Eppure, secondo un sondaggio
realizzato dall'istituto di ricerca SWG,
solo qualche mese fa:
il 15% di noi italiani
crede che la Terra sia piatta;
il 29% sostiene che lo sbarco sullo Luna
non sia mai avvenuto;
e il 18% è convinto esistano
alieni mutaforma tra noi,
i cosiddetti "rettiliani".
I rettiliani!
Nel 2023!
Quante volte, in questi ultimi anni,
abbiamo sentito nominare
l'espressione "fake news"?
Eppure, il fenomeno delle false notizie
non è certo una novità,
nella storia dell'uomo.
La donazione di Costantino,
un falso editto imperiale
che ha giustificato il potere temporale
dei papi durante il medioevo;
la presunta morte di Napoleone del 1814,
che ha fatto crollare la borsa di Londra;
o il tristemente noto
"Protocollo dei Savi di Sion",
un falso documento
che ha diffuso l'odio verso gli ebrei
durante il regime degli zar,
che poi è stato ripreso, anche,
dalla propaganda nazista.
Che cos'è cambiato, allora?
Perché oggi filosofi, psicologi,
sociologi, giornalisti,
perché così tante persone
sono interessate alle fake news?
Perché siamo in una condizione nuova,
che non è mai stata sperimentata
prima dall'essere umano.
Noi oggi viviamo, a tutti gli effetti,
in due realtà:
quella del mondo fisico,
e la realtà virtuale.
Questa nuova condizione
dell'esistenza umana
è descritta efficacemente
dal termine "on-life":
questo neologismo è la fusione
delle parole "online" e "life", vita;
e sta a indicare
quanto la nostra quotidianità
sia ormai caratterizzata
dalla connessione costante a Internet.
Mentre passeggiamo,
mentre facciamo la spesa al supermercato,
mentre svolgiamo le nostre
attività di tutti i giorni,
attraverso i nostri smartphone
noi inviamo e riceviamo
costantemente contenuti digitali
sotto forma di messaggi di testo,
messaggi audio, foto, video, meme.
Nella storia dell'umanità,
l'uomo non ha mai avuto così facilmente
la possibilità di produrre
e condividere contenuti.
Oggi siamo, al tempo stesso:
lettori, ma anche autori;
consumatori, ma anche produttori:
basta un qualsiasi device
connesso alla rete
e in pochi istanti possiamo pubblicare -
postare, condividere, diffondere -
un qualsiasi tipo di contenuto,
gratis e in totale libertà.
E in questo mare di contenuti digitali,
circolano anche le fake news.
A dire il vero,
negli ultimi anni ci si è accorti
che il termine fake news non descrive più
quello che sta succedendo.
Da un lato, ci si è accorti
che non diventano virali
solo pseudo notizie,
o falsi articoli di giornale.
Anzi, molto spesso diventano virali
contenuti di vario tipo,
come appunto foto, video, meme.
Dall'altro, non si tratta nemmeno più
di contenuti totalmente fake,
ma sono contenuti genuini
che vengono alterati,
modificati, decontestualizzati
per ingannare gli utenti,
per manipolare le nostre convinzioni,
o per radicalizzare le nostre idee
su qualcuno o su qualcosa.
È per questo che oggi si parla
di "ecosistema della disinformazione":
o se preferite, disordine informativo.
I contenuti disinformativi sfruttano
la nostra vulnerabilità psicologica:
i cosiddetti bias o distorsioni cognitive.
Sfruttano, cioè, la nostra inclinazione
a credere in qualcosa,
se questo qualcosa conferma
ciò che noi vorremmo fosse vero.
O ancora, la tendenza che abbiamo
a rifiutare prove,
dimostrazioni e dati oggettivi
che vanno contro le nostre convinzioni.
Infatti, abbiamo creato
un modo di essere "onlife"
dove le conversazioni
si sono trasformate in conflitti,
dove non c'è più spazio per l'errore -
che dovrebbe essere umano
per antonomasia -
e per quella cosuccia
che ci distingue dalle altre specie,
oltre al pollice opponibile:
l'empatia.
A complicare ulteriormente la situazione,
ci aggiungiamo anche
il funzionamento di Internet,
e delle piattaforme digitali.
Solitamente, quando navighiamo in Internet
pensiamo di essere in questa condizione:
al centro ci siamo noi, gli utenti,
che abbiamo la possibilità
di entrare in contatto
con un qualsiasi tipo
di contenuto ci interessi:
naturalmente, alcuni argomenti
saranno presenti in più siti;
altri lo saranno meno,
perché più settoriali o specifici.
Con le nostre azioni,
noi possiamo scegliere.
Questo è quello
che siamo portati a pensare.
Crediamo, quando navighiamo online,
che la ricerca sia libera.
Questo, invece, è quello
che succede in realtà:
Quando noi navighiamo in Rete,
i contenuti che possiamo vedere -
e non quelli che potremmo vedere -
sono filtrati dalla nostra
"impronta digitale",
ovvero dalle nostre abitudini online:
in base ai siti che visitiamo,
ai video che guardiamo,
alle nostre interazioni-reazioni
ai contenuti social,
motori di ricerca, e piattaforme,
ci propongono contenuti e risultati
adatti ai nostri gusti
e alle nostre preferenze.
E questo si applica a tutto,
dagli acquisti online
fino alle nostre convinzioni
su grandi temi come guerre,
pandemie, vaccini, leader politici.
E il motivo è molto semplice:
se le piattaforme non ci proponessero
contenuti che soddisfano i nostri gusti,
noi smetteremmo di usarle.
E più noi usiamo una piattaforma,
e il servizio che ci viene offerto,
più questa piattaforma guadagna.
Insomma, l'obiettivo primario
dei signori della Silicon Valley
non è quello di accrescere
la nostra conoscenza,
ma è quello di accrescere
il loro profitto.
E per farlo sfruttano
meccanismi prettamente umani:
ci propongono contenuti
che ci danno ragione,
che si accordano alle nostre convinzioni,
siano essi veri, falsi,
manipolati o distorti.
La disinformazione sfrutta
il funzionamento della Rete,
sfrutta le debolezze umane,
e ha un unico obiettivo:
provocare in noi una reazione.
Una reazione che può essere di meraviglia,
di stupore o di rabbia e indignazione;
o ancora, di pietà e misericordia.
Prendiamo, per esempio, questo contenuto.
Quella che state vedendo è un'immagine
che è circolata moltissimo,
ed è circolata perché mostra
gli effetti del cambiamento climatico
su un orso polare.
Non è vero:
in realtà, questo orso polare
presenta tutti i sintomi,
purtroppo, di una grave malattia.
Più forte è la reazione,
più alta sarà la probabilità
di condivisione e diffusione:
la disinformazione si nutre
dei nostri sentimenti,
dei nostri stati d'animo,
fa leva su questi per diffondersi
quanto più capillarmente possibile.
E proprio come Ulisse,
che chiese ai suoi compagni
di legarlo all'albero maestro,
per resistere al canto delle sirene,
come facciamo noi, oggi,
a resistere alla tentazione
di condividere un contenuto
che ci colpisce,
e che magari potrebbe essere utile
per qualcuno che conosciamo,
per qualcuno che ci sta a cuore?
Insomma, la domanda è sempre la stessa:
noi che cosa possiamo fare,
di fronte a tutto questo?
Di fronte all'ennesima sfida
che sembra essere più grande di noi?
Il modo migliore per resistere
al canto delle sirene
è quello di non ascoltare
il canto delle sirene.
E per farlo, dobbiamo smettere di pensare
che le regole del mondo fisico
siano adatte anche per la realtà virtuale.
Pensiamo che l'atto della lettura
sia sempre lo stesso,
indipendentemente se stiamo
leggendo qualcosa online
o sulla carta stampata.
E ci viene insegnato,
fin da quando siamo piccoli, a scuola,
che per comprendere un testo
dobbiamo leggerlo attentamente
per coglierne il senso,
e poi essere in grado di rispondere
alle eventuali domande -
insomma, la classica
"comprensione del testo".
È per questo che, per riconoscere
la disinformazione online,
noi dobbiamo leggere
attentamente un contenuto
alla ricerca di eventuali errori
o di eventuali incongruenze,
dobbiamo chiederci chi è l'autore
del contenuto stesso,
dove e quando questo contenuto
è stato pubblicato.
Tutte cose che vanno benissimo:
ma il fatto è che noi,
online, non leggiamo:
noi scansioniamo il testo,
saltiamo da una parola all'altra
mentre pop up, banner pubblicitari,
notifiche e distrazioni di ogni tipo
cercano di attirare la nostra attenzione.
Credo che, anche se volessimo adottare
un tipo di approccio scrupoloso,
e quindi leggere attentamente
tutti i contenuti
in cui ci imbattiamo on-line
per cercare le caratteristiche
che fanno di un testo un buon testo,
beh, il fatto è
che chi diffonde disinformazione
questo lo sa benissimo.
Chi diffonde disinformazione
non vi dirà mai:
"Hey, guarda che ti sto ingannando!"
ma farà di tutto
per presentarvi un contenuto
nella maniera più accurata possibile.
Farà di tutto per rispettare quelle regole
che ci vengono insegnate da sempre
per rendere un contenuto credibile.
Senza contare che,
anche se volessimo approcciarci
ai contenuti digitali
con una analisi scrupolosa,
probabilmente
non riusciremmo a riconoscere
l'autenticità di contenuti come questo:
OK, forse qualcuno di voi ha riconosciuto
la faccia di Sylvester Stallone
sul viso del protagonista
di "Mamma ho perso l'aereo":
ma il punto, qui,
è che questa manipolazione
non è frutto della mano umana,
ma di un software che sfrutta
l'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Senza entrare troppo nello specifico:
oggi noi, grazie a un semplice programma,
possiamo creare immagini e video
totalmente falsi, ma realistici,
possiamo sostituire la faccia di un attore
con quella di un altro,
oppure possiamo trasformare
Papa Francesco in un trapper.
Ogni tentativo di analisi,
anche la più scrupolosa,
non sarebbe in grado di stabilire
se un contenuto del genere
è vero, falso, manipolato
o creato dall'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Dobbiamo allora, forse,
sviluppare un approccio nuovo
verso i contenuti digitali.
Dobbiamo sviluppare un tipo di lettura
che non sia una lettura tradizionale,
ma una lettura adatta
alla realtà virtuale.
Di solito, quando noi leggiamo un testo
sulla carta stampata,
leggiamo verticalmente:
dall'alto verso il basso,
riga per riga, parola per parola.
E tendiamo ad applicare questa tecnica
anche quando siamo online:
noi "scrolliamo",
scorriamo lo schermo
del nostro smartphone.
E potremmo scorrere
decine e decine di volte
contenuti come quelli
che vi ho appena mostrato,
e non saremmo comunque
in grado di stabilire
la veridicità o l'autenticità
di questi contenuti.
Dobbiamo trovare un nuovo modo di lettura:
una lettura che sia efficace,
ma al tempo stesso economica,
che ci faccia risparmiare tempo, energie
e soprattutto attenzione.
Dobbiamo passare
da una lettura tradizionale
a una lettura digitale,
da una lettura verticale
a una lettura laterale.
Così.
Quando siamo di fronte
a un contenuto che ci meraviglia,
che ci sembra troppo bello,
o troppo brutto, per essere vero,
noi non dobbiamo leggerlo;
o meglio, dobbiamo leggere lateralmente,
dobbiamo sfruttare tutte le risorse
che il web ci mette a disposizione,
e rompere, finalmente, quella bolla
in cui siamo confinati
quando navighiamo online.
In altre parole,
dobbiamo aprire più schede
nel nostro browser,
e nel nostro motore di ricerca;
dobbiamo cercare altre informazioni
sul contenuto che stiamo leggendo,
dobbiamo verificare altri siti
e come questi siti parlano
del contenuto stesso.
Solo così, con un tipo
di lettura laterale,
forniremo alle nuove generazioni
tutti gli strumenti necessari
per far fronte alle sfide che il digitale,
e l'Intelligenza Artificiale,
porranno alla nostra società
nei prossimi anni.
E soprattutto,
dobbiamo introdurre questo tipo
di lettura laterale
fin dalle scuole dell'infanzia:
dobbiamo introdurre un'educazione ai media
che non sia un semplice adattamento
di quello che già viene insegnato,
ma un'educazione mediale che sia semplice,
efficace e applicabile da tutti.
Ricordate il panico scatenato
dalla trasmissione di Orson Welles
sugli alieni?
Beh, nonostante i giornali
abbiano riportato
la notizia di un'ondata di panico,
la sera della messa in onda del programma
nessuna isteria di massa
si diffuse nelle città americane.
Perché, allora, i giornali americani
avevano riportato un fatto non vero?
Per paura.
Perché avevano paura della radio.
Avevano paura di un nuovo mezzo
di comunicazione
che si stava imponendo,
e che stava già facendo
una spietata concorrenza
alla carta stampata.
Per questo i giornali riportarono
la notizia di un panico di massa:
perché volevano accusare la radio
di essere un mezzo per manipolare
le menti delle persone.
Demonizzando lo strumento radio,
volevano affossarne la diffusione.
Sappiamo poi tutti come è andata a finire.
I progressi e le innovazioni tecnologiche
difficilmente si possono arrestare,
e ogni tentativo di censura
non fa i giusti conti con la storia.
Siamo di fronte ad una nuova rivoluzione,
un nuovo strumento
si sta imponendo nelle nostre vite:
saperne leggere i rischi,
e le potenzialità,
dipende solo da noi.
Grazie.